I also have I'm trying to break my
addiction destiny I don't know but imma
have to go to meetings but my addiction
toward stalking people on Instagram also
has to stop mm-hmm I'm obsessed yeah I
get obsessed with people and I and I got
to stop it
I have a lot of problems right now man
I'm in my mid-40s I might have been
having a midlife crisis
I'm kind of lost you know in like
obsessions are you gonna buy a
motorcycle in a Ferrari did you have a
motorcycle no we got rid of that well
she sold it they sold it right get rid
of what you gave it away
borrowed it's barley right now spot on
yeah so um yeah you guys don't know how
old are you George again oh so I'm
pretty much the oldest to here mmm by a
long by a long way I think right you're
37 so I'm eight years older than you I
think my face looks pretty young you
look amazing
I am in just absolute envy of how young
you look it's so unfair yeah but inside
my body is pat morita like broken down
about the die I'm about to die in it
yeah and another thing is that I think
about my parents a lot lately like I
think I lay in bed and I think there's
my dad gonna die I could think that
because it can happen at any moment and
when you get into this age you it's
inevitably gonna happen sooner than
later and you think about it and you
obsess about it can I give you like
words of wisdom coming from somebody who
thought about her dad dying for four
straight years hmm it's thinking about
it and obsessing about it every day
didn't make it any less or more painful
when he finally did pass so for three or
four years my dad was basically like
bedridden incapable of moving around
like very very sick right and every day
I thought am I gonna come back from
school and as you know I'm gonna find
him dead on the bed you know is the I
every day I just thought I would get
that phone call so it was always like 10
but you know the day that he finally
passed I thought to myself that having
three years of that would make it less
painful for me like okay I already know
he's gonna pass inevitably so maybe when
he does pass I'll accept it much quicker
and he didn't it was just as painful
whether whether you're prepared or in
fear of someone's death it is just
painful I'm just saying that there's no
point in obsessing about it every day or
having it worry you or or thinking or
thinking that you might prepare yourself
for it because it's the the the final
outcome is just going to hurt no matter
what so just accept that at the end of
it it's just going to hurt a lot and
that's okay that it hurts a lot but then
you question you also question then like
where do we go is there a God and all
those like things what do you believe in
I don't know did you say hey is
Christian based no it's not no okay
it's I mean it's it's there's elements
stolen from maybe there's a book called
Sermon on the Mount in the Bible or
whatever but there's a lot of things
taken out of the Koran and other things
also you have to believe in a God right
name well know you believe in a higher
power but it's not even that it's is
that what you know do you have
consciousness I mean are you aware that
your dad is or something or or are you
just like absorbed into this gigantic
energy ball or is it something that we
don't even know what it is like an
endless sea of black nothingness and
you're like a tennis ball floating in it
and you just you're Lily you look you
were like a tennis ball I'm floating in
his black nothingness and then like once
every 3,000 years
another tennis ball will float next to
you and you can't say hello you just
float next to each other and you drift
drift apart and that is a nightmare I
want before I die for there to be a
technology to download all my
information from my brain my character
my experiences my fears my loves and
then to be able to put that into
something in the future whether it's
like a robot yeah but I want it to be
download
well you know hold the hands and the
feet will be rusty because of the water
I do envy people who are who are
religious like my aunt has cancer right
now and she's in so much peace and she's
just like look like she's just so much
faith in a process that I don't believe
in so in a sense like I am very very
envious of people who have a God that
they turn to for everything they have
this radical acceptance of everything
that may happen because it's his plan
and there is a huge safety in that and I
envy that because I don't have that it's
a gigantic safety mm-hm it's you know if
you if you're an atheist and you believe
in nothingness that I believe that you
live every moment to its fullest but
it's like inevitably how do you not
think of the afterlife I'm sorry this is
not a supposed to be a comedy podcast
you know because if its coladas birthday
and I want to talk about real things
right now it's is that what I mean I
don't so I I'm caught in between because
I'm in 12-step groups and I believe
there is a higher power and whatnot but
I don't know exactly what it is and just
that question of what is it consumes me
sometimes you know and like where does
my dad go these are believe in anything
you know so um just a frightening
thought and you're young Gilbert how old
are you 27 27 yeah god I mean I had no
thoughts of death at 27 that's not true
I was obsessing about death when I was
16 yeah but when you get to 45 you're
right I mean I was I would think about
every one as well but when you're 45 and
you get closer to the end I think it
intensifies oh I'm sure I can only
imagine yeah I wonder if there's a study
out there that shows like a side by side
of like a link between anxiety and lack
of faith I think that people who don't
subscribe to a religion I I guarantee
you have a general have are generally
more anxious than the people who
believe in something because there's so
much uncertainty in what I feel every
day because I don't I I don't subscribe
to any any of that I don't I don't think
that there's a God that dictates how my
life is gonna pan out and it does it
does make me anxious but could I say I
know but it's funny because I do know a
solution what's the solution it works
every time
and I haven't been doing it
double-suicide
know and I want to see something really
cheesy but for me it's a truth if I just
get out of myself
and not think about myself and help
other people you just stop thinking
about those kind of things that's true
you know so that's why AAA or 12-step
groups are so helpful because it's a
part of the steps you know they realize
that you know it you know alcoholism and
drug addiction is such a selfish disease
that you know helping others and getting
out of yourself like you know going up
to a newcomer and go ahead you want a
coffee
tell me about how you know how you feel
and what's going on with you you need a
ride home you know things of that nature
or you tend to not think about yourself
and I think that just going giving is
the solution and right now I'm not
giving anything I'm taking [ __ ] from
space am i sucking your soul no healthy
amounts of sucky
[Music]